what's up y'all i'm david bringing you
the best trailers throughout super
mario's history
to help celebrate the series 35th
anniversary now if you're a fan of
everyone's favorite plumber and you want
to see more content covering nintendo
do us a favor and hit that like button
also don't forget to subscribe and hit
the bell
it's free enjoy the show
[Music]
super mario is back he's blasting
through worlds where
no one has ever been he's taking on
enemies no one else dares
this time mario plops up power wherever
he goes
so he's bigger and better than ever
before you've never seen creatures like
these
you've never had an adventure like this
it's everything you've dreamed of and
worlds more it's super mario 2
only from nintendo now you're playing
with
egypt battle all the horrors of the deep
master lots of weird worlds
to give mario a happy ending and make
your world a
better place new super mario land
another exciting game
for game boy nintendo now you're playing
with power
portable power mario
[Music]
mario
[Music]
he's back all you had to do was ask
super mario bros 3 from nintendo
now you're playing with power
[Music]
introducing the next generation from
nintendo new super mario world
created especially for the super
nintendo entertainment system it's
a bit more exciting a bit more
challenging a bit more graphic a bit
more colorful
a bit more realistic with more levels a
bit more secret a bit more enemies a bit
more friends
a bit more sound a bit hotter a bit
cooler a bit weird
what is more revolutionary a bit more
mario a bit more of what you want
it's 16 bit and it's yours only if you
get new super nintendo
now you're playing with power superpower
oh be me you were you i am your master
mario the wicked imposter wario has cast
an evil spell over mario land
don't let mario get the six golden coins
don't let mario reach the palace this is
the biggest most dangerous most
challenging game boy adventure yet
okay
yo listen up we will not live in a
two-dimensional world we won't go in one
direction or ziggler we can set
we will walk through walls we will take
a look around us
we will not be confined we believe in
the path of least limits
we won't be told how to view the world
we will experience
true freedom we will not compromise we
will live the game through our hands
we will be in control of something else
we will change the system
the world of special place cherish life
and never waste
everyone loves a sunshiny day we're
gonna keep it that way that's clean it's
better than dirty and dirty and clean
let's all learn mario can't do it alone
he'll spray his water to fly around and
clean the sludge that's
on the ground that's clean is better
than dirty and dirty
super mario sunshine only for nintendo
gamecube ready for everyone
[Music]
welcome to the new mushroom kingdom new
super mario brothers
this only happens on nintendo ds rated e
for everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go
new super mario brothers finally four
players on the same screen at the same
time
let's say it together because now we can
play it together
rated e for everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
what
[Music]
wow
[Music]
one
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
woohoo
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh yeah mario time
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
wow
[Music]
yep
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
woohoo
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
roof
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
well
[Music]
is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you